6 13 on your wednesday morning what's
driving crazy how about a labor day
weekend travel question that's really
got nothing to do with the backed up
i-15 traffic around prim
viewer becky's questions about the
freeway in the other direction on that
little slice of arizona between nevada
and utah will the i-15 construction
project south towards mesquite still be
down to one lane over the holiday ryan
harding from the arizona department of
transportation's got the answer the
south half of the bridge is currently
being rebuilt so both directions of
traffic are sharing the north half of
the bridge with one lane in each
direction
now he adds once the south half of the
bridge is rebuilt traffic will shift to
that side of the bridge while the north
half is demolished and rebuilt the whole
project set to be completed in the
summer of 2024.
yeah so those delays on the 15 to the
virgin river gorge can be upwards of
half hour you got to be prepared by the
way if you happen to pull over in the
small town of littlefield nearby drop in
on the intergalactic bus stop and tell
chris i said hello i think it's a story
for our george knapp there buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone join the drive any crazy
conversation at traffic eight at eight
news now dot com